chính phụ tế bàn nhà đã thông qua sách lạnh hợp pháp hóa lạnh, cấm vận vốn khi hoàn toàn đối với yên
sau đó mà truyết sĩnh nâng xuất khẩu thiết địa của phòng và sản phẩm lưỡng truyền xa raen.
Đồng thời, cấm nhập khẩu và khoảng bá hàng hóa dịch vụ, có ngôn góc tự các khu địa cơ yên xa raen ở mơ tay.
Các càng và sân bay của tế bàn nhà cũng bị đám cửa đối với cái chuyện hàng như liệu,
có thể được sự dụng cho một bếc quan sử, để phăm nay năm trong chiến sát kiến,
được tụi tướng phê trô sân chết xe công bố và nánh lập trường này can kinh sẵn của tế bàn nhà chức tình hình dài ca ra.
Chỉ phụ hình định sẽ báo cáo đình kì, để bảo đảm vì thực dì.
Sẵn lành có hiệu lực nê lập tức, nhưng cân được hội phê trường trong bà mình ngày.
Cùng thời điểm tụi tướng sân chết tại liên được góc tế thực kêu hỏi tụi đồng của tế công nhận nhận nước Palestine.
Nhân mạnh đây là chí hoa chứ một dạy phá phá phá bình bình vấn dợi chí môi hành hành nâng.